you know i want to bring up the story uh
about ethan klein oh yeah ethan klein is
a podcaster he's particularly prominent
and uh
he recently called for a terror attack
against the nra and it's funny ethan
klein has been calling for you know gun
restrictions gun control but he's just
on his own podcast exemplified exactly
why people probably need guns for
self-defense
on his show last week youtuber ethan
klein calls for bombing of nra
conference
klein prefaced his calls for violence by
promoting sales of his new shirts which
read and gun violence so uh he
immediately walks it back
he's i don't want to play it because i
think youtube
doesn't does it doesn't allow this stuff
even in in this context there's a few
things i want to point out about this
uh allies you know liberals in the media
are saying ethan cline was joking about
doing it
his wife says i feel hopeless like
there's nothing we can do i'm
paraphrasing and he says does anyone
know what's going on that nra conference
calls for extreme violence against it
his wife then says
and that's what
is what really got me i'm like yo he
just said to told your audience of
millions of people to commit a terror
attack and you were like
no no no his producer apparently said
something and then he immediately walks
back like okay no no no don't do that
don't do that
apparently during the show as well he
told people to fire guns into the air
what and then when he was also told like
no don't do that the bolts come back
down he said okay well blanks just fire
blanks he called for uh
sticking a a piece of wood into the into
the texas governor's wheelchair to cause
him physical injury i guess the video
ends up getting taken down he's been
suspended from youtube for a week and
his immediate reaction was to say you
know he doesn't believe in violence but
republicans of the party have dead
children and that now they're harassing
themselves death threats and their
anti-semites so
it's it's mind-numbing you know that
this is the the current state of
politics
i genuinely i i seriously i wonder why
it is people would be entertained or
like that they would like that idea
yeah i don't know who would watch a show
like that and be like yes that's a good
thing and i will defend that there's a
lot of people apparently you know isn't
this the story of the past six years the
one side telling the other what they
shouldn't do but at the same time
advocating for
much the same themselves it just doesn't
doesn't make a lot of sense but there's
an audience for it apparently wow yeah
no cat kathy griffin with the trump head
severed head
um madonna's saying she wants to blow up
the white house snoop dogg
shooting
coming to kids wood chipper
yeah yeah yeah i got
people like this can make threats
towards anyone whose political views are
unpopular and that's considered
completely socially acceptable which is
kind of one of the reasons you need to
arm yourself well right so my response
now is if anyone ever says why would
anyone in this country need a gun i
would say uh because a popular liberal
youtuber called for a terror attack on a
on a convention because uh guy who
worked for disney called for throwing
children into a wood chipper because a
comedian who does cnn's new years showed
herself a mock uh help holding up the
severed head of the president you know i
can go on
but as long as they want to say stuff
like that i'm i'm i'm going to exercise
my right to keep bear arms look i've
been i've been we've gotten death
threats we've gotten swatted eight or so
times we've had the bomb squad come out
here yeah uh
these people are not doing themselves
any justice by saying there's no reason
to have guns when they are you know
advocating for calling for violence and
then you see the george floyd riots and
then as i'll say that i'll be like well
um why would people need guns um
because in 2020 we saw the worst race
riots we've seen in the past 50 years
with over 2 billion dollars in in
tracked damage
probably more damage than that but the
insurance companies only paid up to that
much you saw around 26 to 30 or so dead
people from those riots i kind of think
the left has
absolutely absolutely done everything in
their power to make sure we truly
understand why we need guns well yeah
they call for insurrection and threaten
to riot every single time something
doesn't go their way but we remember
what happened also during the riots when
the police were called they were
wouldn't go into some areas you were
left to your own devices there were
business owners that thought all i want
to do is kind of guard my storefront and
i'll call the police if there's an
attack and they did so
and the police couldn't or wouldn't come
in there so
yeah that seemed to prove the point and
then you have david doran who was
murdered trying to protect you know he
was an off a retired cop and tried to
protect his friend's pawn shop during
those riots and he was murdered you know
so
and i think what's also upsetting is the
uh the exact opposite with trump and
january 6 and in his language it was the
not even remotely anything like what
this clan guy is saying um he was saying
very
normal things that politicians say when
they're upset about elections and and uh
using the same sort of language and then
he also said i think it was up to you
know at least 10 000 national guard
troops i want there and it was nancy
pelosi who turned them down so
everything is uh you know twisted
exactly the opposite you know you know
what i was thinking when i was seeing
the story about uh ethan and atrie
podcast is that he got started by doing
edgy comedy on reddit and youtube
no political background not well versed
in politics but because politics has
become pop culture he's adopted politics
so now he's getting more political
because this is what people care about i
mean the market dictates
for me it's kind of the other direction
i started with political activism
working at non-profits and then moved
into media
so i think for me it's like i come from
a place where i've lived it i've
experienced it i've been reading about
it i've been actually advocating for
policy back you know when i used to do
the nonprofit stuff and now here i'm in
media talking about all this
and there's a large conversation uh
ethan klein's podcast has comparable
viewership to our podcast and so he's
got millions of followers who watch this
but they're getting a pop culture
perspective on political issues with
with limited knowledge and very short uh
relative knowledge so you know we we've
had some of these leftists on the show
they're like i was too young during job
i don't remember obama i was 12. you
know it's like 22 now i have no idea
what happened and so you know for for
many of us especially the you know
people who watch in the key demo
oh we remember what it was like under
obama under biden we remember that the
killing of the americans without charge
or trial the killing of american
children the drone strikes on civilians
we remember the corrupt dealings many
people have no idea so you'll get
someone like ethan klein i think he's
like a year older than me doing a show
where all of a sudden he's in politics
it would be akin to me one day saying
we're a football podcast now because
people like football and we're going to
talk about football yeah we'd retain
viewership we'd slowly start building up
that audience but i have no idea
anything about football well it's scary
to realize as i do probably older than
the oldest person in this room
that there are people that don't
remember 10 years ago if people started
watching the news and there's obviously
a whole generation of kids
that wasn't watching news until 2016 and
post which is i think when there was one
of the biggest fastest transformations
of what we see as news with all the fake
fact checks and so on and the bias
that's all they know that's what they
think the news does the news tells you
what to think the news tells you who's
right and wrong you know gives gives
their opinion and tries to force that
down your throat and the new sensors so
that you don't think the wrong thing
yeah absolutely and just
when you look at how bold they're
getting and how just embolden people who
are on the side of the establishment
feel
to you know spew this kind of violent
rhetoric could you even imagine
a mainstream celebrity or youtube
celebrity who just began to comment on
political issues from a conservative
perspective said that people should bomb
some left-wing organization so that they
should do that like the aclu or a
planned parenthood conference or
something like that i mean first of all
it would be a story ever that everyone
was talking about but it would also be
used as an excuse to censor every single
other conservative in the sphere because
they would say well this one guy was a
radical lunatic and so that means we
need to censor everyone else who's ever
associated with them or is near them
because we're just going to get more of
this unless we really stomp down on it
quickly but he can say something as
horrific as this which is literally a
direct incitement to terrorism and it's
totally acceptable he goes well i'm
sorry i'm sorry guys and then it just
goes away i don't think he said he was
sorry at all actually wow okay fantastic
i think he said i got a little
passionate there i should walk that back
and then later came out and said it was
a joke and i'm like dude you weren't
joking and your wife agreed with you and
you said it it was only after your
producer or somebody you like he looks
over at him and then says okay okay i'll
walk that one back got a little
passionate there and then he called for
other things like firing guns into the
air which is lethal like it's extremely
dangerous don't don't blanks also kill
you if they fall well blanks don't
reject anything well if you put a blank
up to someone's head yeah you're a blank
cartridge he was saying fire into the
air there's nothing that comes out it's
just a blast but you know a crazies
would hear that and then and take it a
step too far so i mean it's incitement
but it's just if anyone on the right or
any one anti-establishment said that
their channel would be removed
immediately permanently permanently yeah
and that's and they would get banned
across the board from every other
platform yeah has he been banned
elsewhere he's been banned donald uh
facebook or instagram
no i don't know about that he's
suspended for a week can i ask you from
just youtube or anything yeah yeah just
youtube just as it was none of the other
ones no no no just a one-week suspension
alex jones said something yup i'm going
to say you know he said to people
to what he said get your battle rifles
ready because blah blah blah oh yeah and
he was saying that it was figurative
they didn't care they said you're gone
yeah also yeah which is a much more
reasonable explanation right there is no
figurative version of go bomb these
someone at this time yeah someone should
go bomb this group that's not
figurative that is a clear-cut literal
statement you can't fall back and it was
just a joke guys
alex jones
from everything ethan klein does it of
course here's another thing that they do
on the uh these leftists will say we'll
call for violence and then they'll say
in minecraft
and i'm like oh please that that doesn't
work legally but apparently it does
because they're not getting raided by
the feds they're not getting suspended
they will say things like people need to
take up their guns and go
attack
this group in a video game and then and
they're like oh well we can't ban it
when when the news cycle changes to
being outraged about like a phony
insurrection they're going to get up on
their high horse about how insurrection
is horrible even though they're
constantly calling for violence there
was that mom that spoke at one of these
school board meetings where the parents
have been around the country kind of
irate about all the things going on i
mean the domestic terrorists yeah yeah
that's right yeah and she said something
like i'm coming here monday fully armed
if you
if you make the kids wear masks whatever
it was we're not having it anymore and
they arrested her for that and she said
she was being figurative she meant arm
to she said something that she said we
mean to unseat you right i didn't mean i
was going to come and
hurt anybody
but yeah they so they arrested her but
they didn't arrest klein because he's
calling for physical harm also on
actually
physical harm on the governor well yeah
he didn't mean it real fast i gotta so
he was just joking did you guys remember
uh boogie he fired a gun into the air oh
yeah you guys know the story he's a
youtuber and somebody said
and he pulled out a 22 and he like
raised it up and fired he got charged
for that i'm pretty sure he got arrested
and charged that's something so yeah my
point here is um
what what
he walked it back right away until he
got a little passionate i don't know if
that's an affirmative defense for a
direct incitement to terror to be to be
honest like i don't know if you can call
for something like that on a show to
millions of people and then when walking
it back if people say they still heard
it and that still you know told them
what you thought yeah so i i don't i was
gonna do it i'm not a lawyer but i'm
wondering if when you get arrested for
terroristic threats if you said i
immediately said no
it probably mitigates it but i'm not
sure at a rate yeah i i think the
response from the d.a would be so you
confess well yeah well and also is if
some maniac in his fan base who would
commit an act of violence is gonna go oh
he said he got too passionate i'm not
gonna do it now right i gotta be honest
though i don't i don't really care all
that much
in the sense that
i don't expect him to face any
repercussions from this i'm surprised he
got suspended it took like a day or two
before he actually had any adverse
reaction from youtube which was
surprising
he he made multiple calls for threats of
assault or violence people to understand
about assault is that depending on your
jurisdiction assault doesn't mean
physically attacking someone it's verbal
it can be verbal or it can be an action
so in illinois assault is putting
someone within reason within reasonable
fear of harm so when he called on people
to fire blanks he's calling for people
to assault the home of the governor
depending on the jurisdictional context
i'm not sure texas has that in new york
assault is causing actual physical harm
that means that if someone grabs you but
doesn't cause any visible bruise the
cops are going to be like no assault
occurred which is which is weird so it
depends on jurisdiction but when i say i
don't care
nothing's going to happen
i mean i'm surprised it did and
this is we know
we know they did it years ago with the
rights we know they did it in 2017 with
the riots in dc we know they get away
with it we know that dc actually paid
ante for millions of dollars in a
lawsuit or or have to pay after their
charges were dismissed the anti-people
filed the lawsuit and won against the
city so not only do they continue to do
this they continue to escalate it
yeah i accept that as a reality what
what more can you expect do you think
the suspension sort of going off a
little turn here
that you didn't expect on youtube does
that have anything to do with the elon
effect is there are there token steps
being made in some instances now because
everybody recognizes that when things
aren't fair and they're very one-sided
someone like elon could come in and do
something no he couldn't buy youtube and
the fact that h3 wasn't terminated
immediately for this shows the bias
alex jones got wiped out across the
board on every platform all around the
exact same time and it was for nebulous
reasons but if youtube hadn't suspended
this guy for a week would anybody have
raised kane other than people they don't
care about yeah
well it covers them right and it allows
them to say oh no we did take action
against them of course we suspended him
the whole so so the issue here is what
he said was so far beyond what they
could ever try to defend i mean saying
someone should
bomb you know a building or whatever
was so far beyond anything they could
argue was allowed they had no choice and
all they did was give them a single
strike
but it's like they called it bullying
and harassment that's what they did they
said the video's been removed for
bullying and harassment i'm like wow
calling on millions of people incitement
to a terror attack yeah i know i know i
know he walked it back after he got
called out doesn't matter but seriously
we've not been extended that courtesy
when we had alex jones on the show he
made a comment about the death penalty
and i immediately called him out and
said dude none of that you can't say
that and youtube said we don't care and
i was like not only was it not me we
said no to it they're like so what and
we got uh we got a warning because we
don't have uh we didn't have that was
our first warning so for ethan i guess
he's he's already had his warning so now
you get one warning and then you move on
a strike so for us we didn't get taken
down yeah well i think what you said
just going back a little bit what you
said about him switching from being
entertainment into
something he should not be
dabbling in i think that that is also
just kind of generally a broader
cultural problem we have with i mean
just our education system because
you know the university system and now
the k-12 it's like
in in their view they're they're doing
the rules for radicals so for them you
know using this type of aggression or
using uh language that is incitement for
them that that is actually normalized
and that's that's that the culture is
such that uh when it when a conservative
it doesn't even get remotely close to
that uh they can't handle it because
everything the default setting is to be
so hard left because of our education
system and culture and and hollywood and
media so that
it's just a it's all
it's like the soup it's like the crock
pot it's it's
that's what we that's what we soak in
carrie you reminded me that a few years
ago i thought it was a joke a lot of
these things that i hear and i think is
a joke and it becomes true one of them
was there were college campus
authorities as well as students who were
saying
that if you say certain things to people
it's akin to violence
and there was actually a case where a
teacher
at a california college went to court
and argued that these anti-abortion
signs that kids were holding up on
campus were akin to violence against her
she lost the case but i thought the
claim was sort of a joke so at the same
time
some people on that side are claiming
mere
language or mere signs you know
protected free speech and language is
akin to violence by the same token when
that is committed by somebody on that
side it is then
viewed quite differently this is why i
said i don't care
because i think if you haven't realized
by now the asymmetrical cultural warfare
that's been going on
i don't know what to tell you i'm just i
don't think i can keep saying it every
time someone like this happens like
there's a double standard what's
happening it's like yeah that was three
and a half years ago i was talking about
you know the double standard we're
saying nah that i mean i think it was
far more pronounced in the 60s basically
that's when i think the root of a lot of
this started so
i mean it goes back all the way it it
you can trace the the conflict today all
the way back
i mean literally but in terms of like
the erosion of norms of just how
uh uh things that happened in the 60s in
terms of normalizing the breakdown of
the family normalizing the uh the hatred
of men and you know toxic masculinity
and uh weaponizing race like that that
really i think had the genesis most
powerfully in the 60s
and now here we are one of the common
themes we see with a lot of these uh
mass shootings is fatherlessness
yeah yeah family is broken
one thing you don't hear and
some years ago i tried to look into this
didn't get very far but it used to be as
soon as there was a mass shooting there
was a rational discussion or a
reasonable question that was asked as to
what medicine the kids were on because
some of these antidepressants and
antipsychotic medicines can exacerbate
the feelings of violence in some so some
are apparently helped sometimes as it
says on the warning label people become
more suicidal and more violent
all of a sudden i would say around the
2005 time period coinciding with the
pharmaceutical industry getting greater
control in my view over the media and
practically everything else that
question is no longer asked and it used
to be again that's the natural thing you
would ask not that that's the only thing
to blame but you certainly want to know
it's not even asked by the media now
like people don't say was the kid being
treated and what medicine was he on and
just like that's not a question anymore
and i yeah or do you have a father in
the home
but i would bet money that these things
are you know that money that i'd be
willing to bet money the kid has been on
medication yeah for sure and i want to
say one thing before we move on because
i sense that we're about to uh for hilah
to sit there while ethan says this and
just go um i view that as a failure of
being a wife you should call your
husband on his bs right there right then
especially if he has a huge show that
he's trying to make a difference to
people which i assume ethan is trying to
do but i just want to point that out
because that i see that as a cultural
feeling because it seems like women no
longer recognize that they are supposed
to be the check to their man and be like
you know what maybe you shouldn't
actually i don't think ethan is trying
to do anything i don't think he knows
gender w i know terrible i'm sorry i i i
when uh steven crowder wanted to have a
conversation with ethan klein oh yeah
ethan brought in sam cedar instead
ambushing crowder who was like okay
whatever find buy
ethan klein says he doesn't know
anything about politics it's his words
he's correct
but there's there's something that's
fascinating that's happened as
politics has become pop culture
i think the um
i don't know
the establishment class the uniparty the
democrats pelosi type they were so
desperate to defeat donald trump they
did everything in their power to make
politics pop culture and now they will
regret it
they you you do not want
people who have no idea what they're
talking about to be violently angry over
these things it's like all that energy
you see when there's a baseball game
lost or won people right throughout the
city or whatever turn that into a
political issue it's gonna no you know
you don't want that
when i was younger i used to say i wish
people cared more about politics and
then i started to understand the average
person has no interest in actually
understanding it they just want to fit
in yeah and then i'm like okay i want
the people who care about the stuff and
want to help make the world a better
place care about it i i do wish
everybody really did care about it in
the sense that they would read and
understand it what we got now is people
like ethan klein who
has no idea what he's talking about
calls for gun control
and violence against people who have
guns and it's kind of like you're
advocating for guns
you're giving people the reason to need
them but he doesn't care i don't you
know when i think about this idea of the
grifter in the political space
they say like so-and-so is a grift or
whatever it's like let me tell you if
someone is there is career-wise like
their whole life was politics journalism
and news and they talk about those
issues
i probably wouldn't call them a grifter
unless they did specific things like
ethan klein being a a comedy podcast
jumping into politics i'm like yo that
is definition grifting he was like hey
this edgy comedy is no longer good what
do i do let's start a podcast he
interviews jordan peterson well jordan
peterson was getting popular then uh oh
it's not popular with the left so he's
then he takes the episodes down and says
oh i shouldn't have interviewed jordan
peterson he's just doing whatever he has
to do to maintain a product for people
there you go
yeah oh no did you want to
you know that kind of thinking that kind
of behavior it's a you know a problem
with just the total value of virtue or
breakdown of the family but also i i
don't know his specific case but you
look at the way the media you know and
sort of instructs people to behave and
you also look at the way the educational
system here and i have no idea where he
was educated but speaking more broadly
about our culture as a whole i believe
it was thomas soule who made the
observation that kids in school are
taught it's very important to care about
making a difference they're not really
taught that it's very important to know
all that much about the thing you're
trying to make a difference within and
it's very interesting that that's sort
of our cultural ethos i'm going to make
a difference
okay well what kind of different you
know like just because you made
something different doesn't mean you
made it better if you didn't know what
you were doing you probably made it
worse but people aren't encouraged to do
any of the real work that it takes to
become informed about something before
commenting on it
or before
um you know trying to make some kind of
differences and activities
exactly hey that's what kids in school
should be doing but then
outside of that when people go into the
world and they say they want to be an
activist i think there's a fantastic
example of this in uh matt walsh's film
i haven't seen yet but even just in the
the preview where he asks these women at
a women's march what is a woman and they
can't give him an answer that is how can
you be at the woman's march and not be
able to give an answer to the question
can you imagine if you went to like a
gun rights march or something and asked
what is a gun and the person couldn't
give you a definition it's ludicrous let
me i want to point something out this is
someone i saw this in the super chat
this is uh storm biking you mentioned
this trump spoke at the nra event yeah
ethan klein called for terror against an
event that had the former president at
it with secret service details so this
is
i mean it's crazy this state we're in
it's okay because it was against trump
but i'm gonna say though i'm gonna so
guys get ready to drink cause i'm gonna
say those two magic words civil war snap
here here's here's here's what i see um
i think most people who've watched the
show probably heard me make this point
but again i i some people are like i've
heard this before tim not everybody's
heard it boomers are mostly unified in
their politics there's little division
among boomers they do have their wedge
issues gen xers are similar but
millennials are so divided that you can
have someone like ethan klein call for
active terror
like how does that even happen like i
can't imagine growing up someone
accidentally calling for a terror attack
against a former an event with the
former president speaking at it and that
sounds
absurd to me but the point now where
let's just say
he got too passionate that's what he
said and it slipped out
what's the next generation going to be
like
if ethan has no reason to try to to
apologize for this
and he he basically didn't he just said
i got a little passionate and then he
said republicans of the party of dead
children further inflaming tribal
tensions instead of just saying yeah i
should not have said that i'm so sorry
guys we got to tone things down no he
actually escalated the rhetoric against
republicans
if that's the direction things are going
you take a look at how the parallel
economies have emerged there's something
that i warned about several years ago
2018 i said
if we keep seeing censorship
i talked about this with jack dorsey
you will you will force people to to
create a parallel economy if they are to
function banning people and taking away
their livelihood will not stop them from
living it will force them to find
alternate alternate means of trade
eventually you will see a larger and
larger parallel economy separate from
yours
once that happens people will have no
reason whatsoever to accommodate the
other
ethan klein is a perfect example he can
call for this and the only reason in my
opinion he walked it back is because he
knew you two he knew youtube would check
out his income thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time